did you see Biden I know it's incredible
that you shouldn't you see Biden with
Charlemagne then that was insane
no I didn't see he goes if you don't
know who to vote for or you lose if you
don't know not to vote for Trump the new
ain't black
that's what Charlemagne said no no to
Charlemagne and troubling you if you're
still confused about who to vote for
then you're not black and I went Joe
bites it but he's kind of putting some
flavor in the whole interviewer like
yeah what is that when Charlemagne went
Adam didn't let him off the hook when
Adam does I see that yeah you can see
here there's a little clip of it and Joe
but didn't Joe bind those I spent 40
years trying to take out Joe Biden you
see [ __ ] something you like what is
happening dude
are you a robot you can't do that the
black media do that the white medium
black maybe because my wife has to go on
at 6 o'clock okay oh I'm in trouble
listen you gotta come see it when you
come to New York VP Biden well it's a
long way until November we got more
questions you got more questions right
Aaron if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for mere Trump and you
ain't black they don't have nothing to
do with Trump it has to do with the same
but it's really hard time I was the clip
Charlie just whoa yeah sure man bingos
adamant that's [ __ ] weird left-wing
race-baiting [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
silly and I there's another thing
oftentimes Charlamagne he gets really
well-known for like a lot of his like
viral clips where he's going hard on
someone and so I think people make this
association that that's what he is he's
just like edge Lord Charlemagne is so
[ __ ] smart measure he is such a
valuable and an important broadcaster
his like there's not very many people
like Charlemagne he's so [ __ ] good
look Joe Rogan for black people like
he's eligible he's like he really you
know he won't back down from places he
believed some you know mental no I have
not been you know like I've been in the
same room as the
like radio events but III I'm such a big
fan I I like especially coming from that
industry you know like the pressures
that go into not being like him yes ever
such a way like Jesus I start on Wendy
Willy and like for him to ascend the
ranks in popularity the way he has while
also maintaining this this really like
unashamedly even and balanced and wealth
and men thoughtful Zen take really good
when you're that honest like I is what I
notice about him is it he hasn't kissed
anybody's ass when he was interviewing
Kanye West the hard questions he was
posed a which I by the interview I one
doesn't like Nimet you keep talking
about Trump I'm not for what are you
gonna do for the black band he's like
going out and crashing Biden's was it
ready
I might ones not ready he thought was
gonna be softballs no sure lingers horny
people like so that's that's a good
posture or forget being Republican or
Democrat how about just being practical
when you get down to the level of detail
to solve real problems it's all that
ideology goes out the window you got to
get practical that's why I find that
people who have to like make a business
run you ever notice how people have to
make a restaurant run and so they tend
to not want to talk about politics they
just want their practical they tend to
want to be like look that there's their
moderate they tend to be sort of like in
the middle kind of sometimes over here
something anytime you run a business
anytime you it it seems to me that
people who talk for a living like media
people they have the luxury of being all
the way over here or all the way over
there and and around allies I can't do
not only media people but oftentimes
professional intellectuals and I think
that's a big problem with like that's
packaged Amex is that obviously some of
them most of them deserve tremendous
respect for their intellect and the fact
that they've committed their life to
learning something to such a great
extent but the problem is is that for
instance economics if you're an
economics teacher at the highest level
if you're teaching at Harvard Business
School or Wharton School of Business you
see this much you've never run a
business
yeah everything kind of exists it's like
being a martial arts teacher and you've
never in teaching self-defense but
you've never been in a real fight right
you see that alzheimer or be
like a master in a certain kind of
karate or whatever and then like and
then talking about MMA you know there's
something practical about the one of
things I love about MMA is like when I
when I saw yeah you're a Rodriguez I
always talk about this so Brendan I saw
him kicking and doing I was I'm a
Taekwondo guy so I'm watching him do all
these like kicks and stuff and I go but
for real I go yeah he was so good I go
it's gonna be really hard to solve that
problem because he can stand on the
outside and we'll kick you roundhouse
kick you and all that and Brendan said
don't give him the Frankie I don't do
that I go I don't know house Frank Egan
and Brennan said that doesn't work on
the on the on the higher up guys and I
couldn't understand it but unless you
understand that he broke him Frankie
broke him right but but you took three
years you know right away right away why
cuz Brendan had practical experience
having to solve those problems I got I
might have five kicks but I got you you
just you don't understand that unless
you've been doing it for a long time
yeah you got a practical in standing and
then you can you can recognize he saw
that your ear is is really exciting
wonderful but he also saw the guys young
and still has deficits in this game
because he's not an MMA fighter yet not
a complete MMA fighter right but I also
think that's why I like if someone
criticizes a fighter that's why you'll
see me get all stick up for me I'm like
doo doo doo because you've never made
that walk you really haven't been tough
you know I said that's like you're
talking a soldier in a time out the time
you you know you did tours over in Iraq
he never did him looking like what are
you talking about you're so far up
that's not how it works right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]